vi voglio invitare stamattina a visitare
in un tour virtuale riserva del
serengeti in africa non siete mai stati
in africa e io da quando ho iniziato a
preparare questa presentazione mi è
venuta voglia di partire ho iniziato a
mettere solo della parte quando l'ho
detto a mia moglie è saltato in aria
bene la caratteristica di questa riserva
un enorme prateria savane 14 mila
chilometri quadrati dove pascolano in
branchi numerosi un milione e mezzo di
new 500.000 gazzelle 300.000 zebre più
enorme mandredi elefanti giraffe e molte
altre specie di erbivori appunto sono
accomunate da dal vivere in numerosi
branchi che in occasione delle grandi
migrazioni convergono a formare dei miei
che non sono solo milioni di individui
io le vedo anche come milioni e milioni
di chili che vengono a creare un impatto
attraverso loro zoccoli sul terreno
attraverso i loro zoccoli iniziano a
rompere la crosta del terreno permettono
di migliorare l'infiltrazione del
proprio vana mettono a contatto il seme
con il terreno nel modo ottimale e
questo permette di germinare
correttamente
inoltre dall'azione dei loro zoccoli
emergia possibilità di interrare lo
sterco le urine derivante da questo
processo di chiamandolo compostaggio che
avviene nel rumena ma il fatto di vivere
in branchi come potete immaginare non è
così spontaneo e per proteggersi dai
predatori ovvero sono i predatori che
perfetto della loro presenza influenzano
direttamente dal comportamento degli
erbivori stare in branco significa
essere
numerosi sfruttare numero per poter
ridurre il rischio di essere predati
singolarmente mentre quando il
cacciatore il predatore riesce ad
isolare e uccidere un individuo tondo
una selezione genetica a favore degli
individui più forti e più adattati non
solo quando attacca induce di animali a
spostarsi e questo e mentale per la
sopravvivenza delle praterie perché
permette all'air di non essere
completamente pascolate ti dà il tempo
di rigenerarsi non vengono stressate non
solo si come sempre per paura del prete
essere attaccate dai predatori non
possono scegliere non hanno lusso di
scegliere le erbe più buone da quelle
meno buone
perché quanto stanno pascolando
abbassano la testa e diventano delle
prede vengano del una posizione molto
sensibile sono delle facili breve e
quindi devono per forza fare quello che
trova immediatamente e questo è un altro
attore importante perché il pascolare
modo selettivo garantisce dall
opportunità a tutte le essenze erbacee
di crescere ugualmente la co evoluzione
delle praterie delle armi vere e dei
carnivori è così forte che è la
caratteristica fondamentale di tutti e
gli ecosistemi naturali anche l'uomo
faceva parte di questo ecosistema
naturale perché era cacciatore
però poi ha deciso di saper fare meglio
della natura in altre situazioni come un
del nord america ha sterminato i bisonti
per introdurre gli allevamenti di vacche
e le grandi praterie sono state
trasformate in campi per lavorare per le
colture annuali
poi questa cosa si è evoluta e fino
arrivare all'epoca post guerra con
l'introduzione di enorme macchine che
permettessero di fare lavori del terreno
più velocemente
gli animali sono sempre state dimezzate
agricola e letame che nel principale
fertilizzanti e stato sostituito le
fertilizzanti chimici nei concimi
chimici
beh poiché continuato ad allevare ha
deciso che poteva pure fare a meno di
lasciare gli animali a pascolare e le ha
portate nelle strutture strutture che
sono le stalle dove è iniziato
introdurre sempre più innovazione sempre
più tecnologie sempre più costi e questo
cosa ha portato oggi forse in modo anche
non consapevole ed è testimoniato dalla
stampa e dalla crisi
già negli ultimi dieci anni vengono di
pensate di mezzate il numero di stalle
hanno difficoltà e ogni minima
variazione del prezzo di mercato
dell'atto della turner
sono sempre più numerosi gli
stabilimenti che chiudono e alimentato
anche notevoli dibattici dibattiti a
livello internazionale su quello che
l'impatto sull'ambiente o di tipo etico
dovuto a queste questa forma di
allevamento in che direzione si sta
andando bene continuiamo ad allontanare
dalla natura selezionando animale sempre
più produttivi o sempre più belli e
quindi passiamo della selezione
dell'animale più adatte più forte alla
selezione dell'animale più bello
oppure andiamo sempre di più a innovare
a rendere più tecnologiche le spalle
fino a renderle robotizzata beh chi
invece ha deciso di allevare in modo
naturale che cosa fa lascia gli animali
liberi e nel tempo si è formata questa
idea di animale liberi felice che hanno
tutta l'erba a disposizione per
pascolare ma è davvero così romantica la
realtà no
di fatto quello che succede un po questa
situazione un po generica dei nostri
allevamenti
l'animale a libero di pascolare inizia a
scegliere le piante più buone da
mangiare
scarta le altre che con il tempo
virano andranno assieme prenderanno il
sopravvento rispetto a quelle buone
l'animale avranno sempre più difficoltà
a trovare delle essenze buone da
mangiare perché più volte vengono
pascolate mentre crescono e fino ad
eliminarla completamente inizieranno a
comparire piante spinose inizieranno a
comparire piante velenose rovi e questo
determinerà ad un certo punto non si
potrà più andare in determinate aree del
pascolo perché i cespugli spinosi sono
così fitte che non permettono agli
animali di entrare oppure il terreno è
talmente reso libero e sterile che non
riesce più nulla lasciato libero è
oggetto di fenomeni erosivi compaiono le
pietre fino alla completa
desertificazione
l'animale sono sempre più indeboliti e
diventano suscettibili agli attacchi
parassitari e l'allevatore allora che
deve fare
riduce il numero degli animali certo
nuovi pascoli deve spendere soldi per i
mangimi per far stare bene gli animali
deve spendere soldi per vermifughe
antibiotici che vanno a intaccare la
salute del suolo e allora io mi chiedo
se ci sono sistemi diversi per poter
coniugare profitto e sostenibilità
e già stato messo a punto un modello di
produzione suo tecnico che sposa
produttività e cura dell'ambiente ed i
tipi di redditi bilità e sostenibilità
un modello che si basa sui principi
della natura e si si adotta riesce a
curarsi adattarsi al al modello
produttivo aziendale comunque di
produzione ad oggi sono migliaia di
produttori in tutte le parti del mondo
che hanno avviato queste questo modello
di produzione naturale ed è oggi l'unico
modo per noi di andare avanti di dio di
avere un futuro di di a dargli svolgere
il nostro ruolo di predatore e di co
creatore di cura thor del territorio e
del futuro del queste pianeta sono stati
grandi cambiamenti nei ultimi 60 70 anni
nel mondo di produzione e per fortuna è
stato ha messo a punto un modello
completo di produzione che si basa sul
modello della natura che si chiama
l'allevamento rigenerativo ci sono dei
principi chiavi che gasp re ha già
illustrato che sono quelli della natura
il pascolamento ad alta densità il
quarto porta gli animali a consumare
tutta l'erba che nel tempo permette di
produrre più foraggio e dunque di aver
più animali per le aziende di essere più
produttive e di contenere di più di
rimanere in produzione questo si fa oggi
con l'utilizzo di recinzioni elettriche
l'impatto dopo un passaggio di animali
esattamente quello che avviene nel
serengeti un impatto molto molto forte
per breve tempo con lungo tempo di
riposo che poi andata a settimana a mesi
o anche anni dipendente dal dal clima
della stagione
dell'impatto che vogliamo avere quelli
essenze vogliamo fare ricrescere alta
concentrazione di letame di urine e
questo porta a maggiore produttività
anche se sembra andare a contrario di
quello che pensiamo di ridurre il numero
di animali per far produrre di più il
terreno invece la natura come non essere
inviati ci dimostra contro importato un
grande impatto sul territorio non
possono più immigrati animali dunque
dobbiamo adattarsi al al fatto che siamo
in contesti produttivi e dunque è
importante supplementare non con fieno i
grandi quantità di mangime ma aiutarla
animale a digerire meglio il foraggio
anche quando è secco anche quando è
povero sui terreni degradati
dunque tutti questi sono delle pratiche
che consentono di imitare i processi
naturali e comunque mantenere produzione
è quello che permette di avere animali
di buona qualità quello che permette di
sostenere il corpo a diventare forte
quello che permette a grande estensione
di territorio a non diventare deserti
come nella natura i party dove no devono
avvenire in primavera le rondini quando
fanno le uova in primavera come i bovini
devono farlo quando l'erba cresce invece
di farlo in autunno quando gli anni
dobbiamo dargli sostegno e proteggo
minerali e tanto e tanto foraggio al
grande costo gli animali che possono che
devono essere selezionati come nella
natura come il lupo come l'orso come il
leone dobbiamo spingere
sviluppare una selezione basata sui
criteri della natura gli animali che
sono di conseguenza sviluppati sembrano
più ippopotami che bovini sono delle
masse gigante hanno una grande capacità
di rumine perché mangiano erba
tutto questo è normale
allora per quanto può sembrare molto
evidente e semplice sono veramente pochi
a livello mondiale sono centinaia di
produttori dovrebbe essere tutti i
produttori in italia ancora di meno si
possono contarsi sulle dita della mano
conti proditoria utilizzano queste
pratiche in sicilia
figuriamoci per fortuna abbiamo un caro
amico nostro
allevatore di nicosia si chiama mario lo
presti che ha deciso di seguirci in
questa avventura e mettere in atto
queste pratiche e questo è l'effetto 1
prima di tutto è bellissimo è un armonia
con la natura che si si vede troppo
troppo poco spesso dunque lui sta
diciamo mettendo insieme queste queste
buone pratiche e sta gestendo gli
animali come avviene nel serengeti ad
alta densità sta facendo selezione
genetica sta riducendo i costi di fieno
e di mangime utilizzando il secco che
c'è d'estate supplementazione proteiche
e veramente siamo siamo nel momento in
cui possiamo fare scelte perché c'è
tanto veganismo c'è tanto di rifiuto
della kander rifiuto del mondo animale
che ha il suo perché però esiste questo
altro modello di produzione e stanno e
di metterlo in atto stanno e di di
assumere la nostra posizione nostro il
nostro doverci questa pianeta di curare
il territorio
e dunque nonostante ci sia il modello ci
sia chi già fa ad esempio un buon
livello internazionale e qualche esempio
a livello nazionale che segue queste
questo sistema di gestione nonostante è
dimostrato che è possibile ottenere un
profitto in modo sostenibile
anzi migliorando oppure il territorio
l'ambiente
nonostante ciò quello che rimane il vero
fattore limitante proprio l'uomo cioè
lui che ha la facoltà di applicare
qualcosa che è dimostrato semplice e
immediato oppure continuare sulla strada
in questa pista ancora percorrendo e di
cui già sappiamo qual è la fine noi
abbiamo avuto questa questa possibilità
l'esperienza
vi ringraziamo infinitamente della
vostra attenzione